and today I can announce that we will go
even further to provide support for
those in danger of domestic abuse and
I'm launching a new national
communications campaign to reach out to
those who are at risk from abuse
highlighting that they can still leave
home to get the support that you need
it will signpost victims in terms of how
they can access help but also to
reassure them by making sure that they
can access the services that they need
at this particular time and importantly
it will tell them that they are not
alone
coronavirus has opened Britain's
enormous heart and shown our love and
compassion for one another as we come
together to help those who are most in
need and I'm now asking this nation to
use that amazing compassion and
community spirit to embrace those who
are trapped in the horrific cycle of
abuse to help us all look out for those
who need help we have created a new
campaign and we have created a symbol of
hope a handprint embossed with a heart
so that people can easily show that we
will not tolerate abuse as a society I
ask you and I urge everyone to share
this on social media or in the windows
of your own homes just to demonstrate
how much we care and how much our
country cares and also we can show and
take the time out to show the victims of
domestic abuse that they are not on
their own
I'm also providing up to 2 million
pounds to enhance online support
services and the help lines for domestic
abuse so that anybody who needs that
help and support can access that support
these services will be boosted from new
IT provided by the business the company
Fujitsu to assist smaller domestic abuse
charities and they're trained support
workers to provide the crucial services
remotely we all know that there are
concerns about capacity right now in the
system and in particular for refuges to
provide enough spaces
accomodation during these challenging
times now I'm clear about this
it's the perpetrators who should be the
ones that have to leave the family homes
and not the supposed loved ones whom
they torment and abuse our priority is
to get the abusers out but sadly this is
not always possible so we're a victim
and their children do need to leave we
will ensure that they have a safe place
to go to and that's why we are looking
at alternative accommodation to support
those in need at this difficult time